merci cette question du droit de la
nationalité est une très belle question
car au fond elle nous interroge sur ce
qu'est la nation sur ce qu'est la
communauté nationale
je suis de ceux qui pensent que nous
n'avons pas à nous excuser d'être ce que
nous sommes nous sommes une nation
ouverte sur le monde
mais nous sommes aussi les héritiers
d'une histoire d'une histoire millénaire
et au fond d'un certain art de vivre
d'une certaine civilisation ce mot
d'assimilation n'est pas un gros mot
il est profondément républicain c'est en
1945 lors de la refondation de la
république qu'il a été introduit dans le
code civil comme critère de l'accès à la
communauté nationale
c'est à dire comme critère de la
naturalisation
j'ai rappelé à l'assemblée nationale au
mois de juillet lorsque à gauche on
hurlait quand on évoquait ce mot des
simulations ce mot d'assimilation il est
profondément républicain et il
correspond à une réalité être assimilé à
la communauté française à la communauté
nationale
ça veut dire faire le choix de rejoindre
la communauté nationale de respecter nos
lois de respecter nos valeurs
d'apprendre et de maîtriser la langue
française de transmettre aussi à ses
enfants ce patrimoine commun qui
constitue notre nation alors faut-il
aujourd'hui dans la france de 2015
s'interroger au plan juridique et au
plan politique sur les contours du droit
de la nationalité
d'abord je pense qu' il faudra
impérativement abroger les erreurs qui
ont été commises depuis trois ans car
depuis trois ans la logique du
gouvernement socialiste
c'est de considérer que la
naturalisation et le début du parcours
d'intégration au lieu d'être
le résultat du processus d'assimilation
et donc il faudra abroger la circulaire
de manuel valls qui a donné consigne aux
préfets de naturaliser à tout va sans
contrôle et sans règles
première remarque deuxième remarque
faut-il aller au delà
faut-il modifier adapter amender les
règles législatives qui figurent dans le
code civil sur le droit de la
nationalité une question est posée dans
le débat public la question du droit du
sol
certains se sont exprimés fort d'un
certain nombre de réalités de terrain
outre-mer notamment mais aussi en
métropole
à titre personnel je suis de ceux qui
pensent qu'il faut maintenir le principe
du droit du sol parce qu'il est l'un des
éléments de notre identité française
l'étranger qui né en france a vocation à
sa majorité à 18 ans à devenir français
il a vocation mais la république
elle devrait aussi avoir le droit de
s'opposer à l'entrée dans la nationalité
de celui qui ne respecte pas nos lois
nos valeurs
celui qui commet des actes de
délinquance et a fortiori celui qui
commet des actes terroristes
celui qui ne respecte en rien les lois
de la république
même s'il est né en france il n'a pas
vocation à devenir français il doit pas
avoir un droit automatique à devenir
français et sans doute y at il là les
contours d'une évolution juridique
nécessaire à la fois respectueuse du
principe républicain du droit du sol et
adaptées aussi à la réalité de notre
temps pour au fond et je m'arrêterai là
conforter la cohésion de notre
communauté nationale
merci guillaume